95% of businesses should not be spending
money on social media advertising when
you say again 95% of you guys should not
be spending any money on your social
media campaigns on the advertising side
the problem is advertising improves
already existing successful campaigns
and the problem is your current
campaigns aren't good enough
the current campaigns suck and so
throwing advertising dollars on top of
it is not going to help you I like to
think of campaigns as franchises so if
you're gonna start a restaurant and you
want to franchise it out you have to
have one location be successful first
right you can't franchise if you're one
location doesn't work I like to think of
it as a fire so you're successful social
media campaign is your fire and
advertising is the gasoline on top of it
advertising can make your campaign
explode it can make it go to new heights
but you have to have the fire if you
pour gasoline on nothing you're not
going to get a huge spark right you need
to have the fire and that's having a
quality social media campaign your
campaigns aren't good enough yet I also
believe that you can build a huge fire
you can build a forest fire without any
advertising just by having a really good
quality campaign something that you can
be proud of something that you believe
in if the conditions are there if you're
standing for something important
you don't even need the advertising to
help you grow this hopefully is not you
today during my presentation this is
most of your campaigns they're boring
they put people to sleep
they suck that's most of your campaigns
that's 95% of the campaigns out there
they suck think about what you're
putting out there are you actually proud
of it is there any feeling behind it
would you retweet your tweets if it
wasn't you if there wasn't your company
would you share this stuff probably not
and that's the problem
that's the problem with your campaigns
right now you throw advertising on top
of this nothing's gonna happen you have
to make your campaigns better the key
thing to think about is how many people
are actually sharing your stuff whatever
you put up right now you have a little
bit of a following Twitter Facebook
whatever you use and you have a little
bit of a following are people actually
sharing your stuff even though you have
a small sample size do they care enough
to share it because if they don't throw
in advertising dollars it's not going to
do anything for you you have to produce
something that you are proud of